una pequeña victoria pero no a gusto de
todos el lunes la justicia de honduras
condenó al ex militar y empresario
hondureño roberto david castillo por su
papel en el asesinato de la
ambientalista indígena berta cáceres la
sala 1 del tribunal de sentencia
nacional impone una pena de 22 años y 6
meses de reclusión para el ciudadano
roberto david castillo mejía por haber
sido encontrado culpable del delito del
asesinato en perjuicio de la
ambientalista bertha isabel cáceres la
sentencia llega un año después de que el
castillo fuera acusado como coautor e
intelectual de la muerte de la popular
líderes ambientalista el 2 de marzo de
2016 luego de recibir múltiples amenazas
por su oposición a una represa
hidroeléctricas sobre el río walk arq
que la empresa de castillo pretendía
construir para la familia y la
organización de cáceres se trata de un
paso hacia la justicia pero no satisface
las exigencias de justicia del pueblo
lenca seis años en espera seis años de
excusas seis años de
seis años verdad para proteger a una de
las familias más poderosas de honduras
milita la sable para los cuales nosotros
seguimos exigiendo un proceso de
investigación y enjuiciamiento
desde el inicio de las investigaciones
el tribunal de honduras ha condenado a
siete personas pero la pena del castillo
es significativamente inferior a la del
resto de acusados que cuentan con penas
de entre 30 y 50 años de cárcel